ladies and gentlemen just 30 years ago
being a young student in Bratislava I
was looking through the barbed-wire
fence
the infamous of Iron Curtain and I was
wondering how the people on the other
side of the river Danube lived like how
our Austrian neighbors were doing and at
that time I couldn't have imagined that
Europe would be United one day and I
personally would be able to work for her
today I am standing in front of you
ready to serve Europe in yet another
capacity nine members of the party of
the European socialists from across
Europe as required by our internal rule
set in June have granted me they support
and I am truly honored by this trust it
allows me to confirm that I want to be
in the lead and energize our collective
efforts within the Social Democratic
family to push forward concrete
convincing inspiring solutions for the
people of Europe every time period has
its own challenges and this also applies
to our current days we are going through
several societal changes that many
people find threatening I'm talking
about the sense of inequality because
the benefits of globalization are not
distributed fairly and the gap between
rich and poor is widening I'm talking
about the sense of uncertainty because
of digitalization or automation and I'm
talking about migration demography as
well a certain nostalgia for the past
and it's all happening in the world
where the rule based international order
and institutions are being challenged
and where our progressive values are
under pressure but what I find most of
all threatening are false promises
across Europe we hear about simplistic
solutions build on populist
anti-european
orcs and
four big views they exploit people's
fears legitimate disappointment or anger
they still twist and misuse the sense of
patriotism they thrive on divisions and
they often play with fire eager to
destroy our European cooperation our
European dream our responsibilities
politician is to understand why some of
our citizens are responding to them
tempted to turn Democratic tables upside
down building the future by recreating
the past never works
my vision is therefore clear we need our
people from all walks of life in every
corner of Europe to be and to feel fit
for the future I want to increase the
sense of stability and security as well
as the sense of belonging to our common
European project our Europe must have
everyone's back ladies and gentlemen
during my almost a near service for the
European Commission I have seen what we
can achieve together it is clear that in
many areas Europe will have to lead by
example in others we simply have to rise
to the challenge and strengthen or build
our own resources because we cannot rely
on anyone else our destiny is clearly in
our own hands we need to make sure that
the century will be European and it can
be this is why I stand for Europe's
autonomy in key breakthrough
technologies it goes hand-in-hand with
with assertive trade and competition
policies because we need to make sure
that Europe will perform well amidst
fierce competition and be ready to deal
on par with other great powers such as
United States or China that is why I
stand for strong European industrial
policy in strategic sectors through
private public partnerships it is also
vital for our ability to innovate and
our brightest minds working on their
dreams here and not overseas that is why
I stand for constant upscaling of people
from childhood to retirement especially
in green digital and financial skills it
is another must because the top 10
professions of today didn't exist just
five years ago and the pace is just
accelerating all this will define where
the modern businesses and high quality
jobs are created here in Europe and
whether we become frontrunners of the
fourth Industrial Revolution while doing
so the EU must remain the strongest
advocate of our democratic values
freedom justice and Hearns we must fight
against discrimination strive to
eradicate poverty in Europe and in the
developing world and we must lead global
crime in action to protect planet for
our children in my program you will find
more ideas and solutions that I believe
will make the European Union stronger
I'm convinced that this vision stands on
strong feet and is relevant to all our
member states all in all I see our
Europe is confident and proud smart and
green socially fair and showing
solidarity our volumes can and should be
our main assets ladies and gentlemen in
the last ten years I criss crossed
Europe many times and spoke to hundreds
of Europeans in every single Member
State this personal experience source of
my vision and my drive to serve I have
learned that we need our actions to
prove to our people that we truly care
that we are inspired by the work
determination wisdom but also by the
idealism and hope there is one more
lesson I take from my engagements around
Europe to restart the integration engine
we must stop talking about west east
north south
the bridges between the center and the
periphery cities and there were areas
but also between citizens and they
representatives must be solid build on
mutual trust and understanding we have
to get rid of barbed wire fences in our
minds it is responsibility of US
politicians to set the right example
otherwise you are silently sowing seeds
of animosity that some will not hesitate
to reap madam a Monsieur
Rishi Dez's elección de fin de la visage
Ella curve dela hope the demo poor Ally
to laquanda Contino news ombudsman
didn't keep the personality fort diverse
in a Kip kisser her sudio to despise and
candidate SATA said condition que nous
pour que nous pouvons ma-a davao
limousine acción de NOC constituion LSS
par par to a new hope sanika position
man's affair may seem undemocratic at in
opportunity unique to renewal dialogue
avec nozzle actor yet I believe layer
conference than not institutions
democratic I am proud to belong to the
European social democratic and
progressive forces who are well placed
to meet people's aspirations and hope
thank you very much
so thank you very much commissioner vice
president just in relation to if you get
the mandates Jerome uses my name if you
get the mandate how important will it be
to normalize relations with say for
example Russia and even at the moment
the United States and also very quickly
if you don't mind giving me a few words
on a major foreign policy issue which is
trying to preserve the Iran nuclear deal
and in this context I know in terms of
your current portfolio the the energy
union and we get some energy here from
Iran but Washington wants to prevent
that with new sanctions in November so
what's happening in terms of trying to
keep the energy flows coming here from
Iran in the context of the sanctions in
November and just thank you very much
thank you very much for this question I
think in the topic you just read it's
quite clear why we need stronger Europe
why we need more assertive trade policy
why we need more independence of our
foreign policy action and why we need
much faster decision-making process
among ourselves the Europeans I think
that the fact that almost every energy
import to the European Union has to be
in dollars and that we are so much
dependent on the American financial
systems is just showing us how it limits
our foreign policy action I think that
Europeans did a great job and I pay a
lot of credit to federica mogherini for
her tenacity to get to this deal done to
to clinch that agreement which was
extremely difficult and we are
explaining to our American partners that
for us it's just not economic issue for
all it's an issue of security we have
enough troubles in our neighborhood and
therefore we are looking for the ways
how we can make sure that we would
uphold the deal that we would provide
adequate assurance to to our companies
and prepare for any eventualities after
the November but I think in the long run
it's quite clear that we must transform
Europe into the truly international
world currency where we would in
world energy for euros and cell for
example our aircrafts in euros as well
because it would give us much more
possibility how to be active and
efficient in in in foreign policy and I
would say the same applies to Russia I
think we so far despite very often
difficult discussions have common
position on sanctions we are strong
supporters of Ukrainian reforms and you
know how much we work on making sure
that the gas transit flow through crime
would continue in post 2019 period but
this is of course the issue which would
be on our table for a long time and I
think that Europe would be in better
terms with these big powers then it
would be stronger more efficient and
we'll be able to adopt the decision much
faster thank you very much for coming
thank you